la guerre en ukraine l'europe réitère
son engagement et son soutien vis-à-vis
de kiev l annonce ce lundi une nouvelle
aide de 500 millions d'euros sur le
terrain les ukrainiens revendique une
série de victoires dans le sud bonjour
gulliver craque on vous retrouve en
direct de kiev le président zelensky
assure avoir repris trois localités au
total dans le sud et dans l'est
oui je pense que la localité la plus
importante dans le sud de l'ukraine
c'est la ville de vis au coop il ya qui
est dans le nord est de la région des
personnes à environ 140 km de la
capitale régionale ce n'est pas une très
grande ville 4000 habitants seulement
mais ça reste la plus grande prise pour
l'ukraine dans la région d'essen depuis
le début de cette offensive pour le
reste sur les détails de comment cette
contre offensive dans la région de
personnes est en train de se dérouler
les officiels ukrainien veut le garder
un maximum de secret ils sortent assez
peu d'informations et de monde aux
journalistes et à la population en
général de se méfier de dévoiler des
informations qui pourraient à mettre en
péril les opérations mais il assure que
les opérations continues est que les
affirmations côté russe comme quoi les
ukrainiens auraient subi des pertes
extrêmement grande et annulé la
contre-offensive sont absolument fausses
mais je pense qu'il est clair que c'est
une contre offensive pour essayer de
reprendre la région des personnes qui va
durer des semaines voire même des mois
puisque le contingent russe dans cette
région est très importante même si les
ukrainiens ont réussi en bombardons les
ponts qui traversent le fleuve dniepr
dans la région de personnes a sévèrement
endommagé la logistique des forces
russes qui ont beaucoup de mal selon les
officiels ukrainien en ce moment à faire
acheminer des munitions et des vivres à
leurs forces qui sont situées côté à
droite du ni pro je vous rappelle la
ville des personnes et rive droite le
reste il ya une partie de la région qui
est rive droite une autre partie qui
ricochent merci pour ces éléments
gulliver crack correspondant france 24 à
quai